こんにちははじめ社長です
なんか俺のゲームが出てるみたいなんです
よはいこちら人生というゲームがなんか出
てますねこれ背中見て分かると思うんです
けどもめちゃくちゃ初め社長に似てるのが
主人公っぽいんですよ
これ何これま人生と言えばそうですよね
こう世界中でプレイされている人生という
ゲーム皆さんもきっと今人生というゲーム
プレイされてるとですけれもま人生なんて
も世界で1番難しいゲームと言われてい
ますまさに皆さんも今プレイ中人生今回
やるこの人生ってゲームなんですけども
なんかサラリーマンになったはめ者との
人生を描いてみましたっていうゲームに
なってるらしいのでちょっとプレイしてみ
たいと思いますねなんかめっちゃリエル
らしいんですよ映像とかもめっちゃ初め
社長本人に近いクオリティのゲームらしく
てあの僕まだプレイしてないんですけど
これ本当僕作ってないんですよ僕作って
ないですし今あの初めてゲームプレイ
しようと思ってるんです本当に何も知ら
ないんですけど
[音楽]
もなんか記憶あるなんでだろうななんか
記憶あるのでちょっと僕がやるというより
ね今回は後輩にこの人生というゲームを
プレイさせてみたいと思います果たして
はめ社長がサラリーマンだったらどんな
人生になっていたのかそんな山あり谷
にやりなはじめ社長の人生というゲーム
やってみたいと思いますでは
行こうはいというわけで田さんはいこれ見
てくださいこちらのゲーム
人生というゲームはい勝ってに作られて
ました勝手に作られたはいはめ社長が会社
員で働いてたらっていう話らしいのでへ
ちょっとたさんプレイしてみてください
これ分かりましたすげえなんかえいな
BGMも映像もいやそうなんだよちょっと
感動するゲームなのかもわかんないです
けどちょっとやってみましょう早速うん
はいじゃあスタートポチ始まった始まり
ました
ねああいきなり本名出たはいサラリーマン
なんですようん
なし趣味はあそんなこと話して
たらDay1キの見てこのクオリティあ
もうクオリティ高初めたんじゃないのこれ
いやでも表情ないから多分ゲームですね
これゲームかあさ会議があるのに寝坊した
とどう
しようあ早速選択肢きましたねこれえどう
ですかどってますかはい
えっとま急いでて遅刻してるんだったら
はいはいはい食パ加えてる場合じゃない
ですかはいまそうとも言いますはいでも
はめ社長の人生なんだっ
たらあえてシパを加え家を出ようかなと
ああいい読みでたなったそれでいき
ましょうはいはいではBの食パンを加え家
を出るにしますお願いしますこちあロード
入りましたおなんだこれロード入ったらあ
ムービーシーン来たムービー
シーン
あ女性かな絶対女性じゃんぶつかっちゃっ
たあっちも食パン加えてるけど
う来いや
んえあの
パンだけで朝ご飯足りますかはいもし
よかったら一緒にカフェでも行きません
かぜひんで近くに美味しいカフェがあるん
で行きましょうあもいい運命的な出会いの
予定あるって言っ食パンが好きなんですか
食パない確かにそうな仕事あるって言って
たよね
うんみんなからはなんて呼ばれてるんです
仕事ないねこの人もうさっちゃんって呼ば
れてますあさっちゃんって呼ばれてるんだ
さっちゃんって呼んでもいいですあぜひあ
ありがとうございます呼んだらいいですえ
僕はそうですねめっちゃリアルじゃね
めっちゃ
リアル初めと呼んでいただけるとあゲーム
という初めドラありがとうございます
どんなお仕事されてるんですか部長から
電話来ちゃってますね好な女性と運命的な
出を果たせも夢中になり仕事ほったらかし
にHPがああ当ったゲームオーバーです
体力やば減っちゃいましたねたさんこれ今
HP減ったと思うんですけどもこれHP
ハピネスポイントらしいですハピネス
ポイントのHなんですねそうですへえぱ
この人生においてやっぱ幸せとか幸福度
ってすごい大事なのでうんうんえたちは
このゲームやっていく上でその幸せに
なれるように選んでいくというゲーム
らしいですなで田さん朝は急いでるのに
食費を食べてはいけませんそうですよね
最初の読みで良かったんですねそうです
わかりましたはいじゃあコデしましょうか
はいなんて最初からうだるでもこうやって
ね何気ない会話からヒントもあるかもしれ
ませんからねああ確か
に素敵な出会いだったんですけどね
うんやっぱ時にはね仕事を優先しなければ
いけないみたいな瞬間もあるんだと思い
ます
うんすごくな表情の
作り込み作り込みすごいっすねほぼ俺だ
けどなさあきましたはいこれはもうだから
真面目にとにかくダッシュを選べばよかっ
たとうんそうですねはいじゃあ絵を押し
ますお願いしますAのとにかくダシュ
[音楽]
ポチ
ドア走り方はちょっと表現難しかったのか
なゲーム確かになんかレトロゲームの走り
方してますけど
[音楽]
間に合ったああ間に合いまし
た出社ですね
うんあああけどやっぱ下がっちゃうんだね
もう寝坊してる時点でねそうだ
ねさ大近夕方
です
終わった今日は頑張ったから早く大金
できるぞ外れな症状
はったから先に失礼するよ
[音楽]
とはいはいはいはいはいはい帰ってますね
はいいやよくできたゲームだなよくでき
てるな仕事がれたから寄り道して帰ろう
暗い道と明るい道どっちに寄っていこうか
なはいはいはいもうこれ難しい選択肢だね
これ難しいな普通だったら明るい道が
ハピネスポイントとしては高そうなんです
そうだねうんこれ難しいっす
ねも暗い道って危ないですから確かに暗い
道危ないねうん逆に
その暗い道に
こそ幸せがあるかもしれないねなるほどね
最初ハピネスポイント減っちゃったから
はい暗い道でちょっとこうチルな感じで
変えろみたいなああはさん確かにそういう
の好きだからねてなるとじゃ暗い道で行き
ますかBではいBの暗い道で行きますお
願いしますB
ポチいやいいと思うよ俺クライム好きだ
もん
[音楽]
うんちょっと木々が追いしげてる道ですね
そうですねえ宇宙人だどんな人生これ唐突
に木の鍵から宇宙人がれたあこれ大丈夫
かやばく
ないいきなり何宇宙人
あやばいやばいやばい連れてれてますね
あ最悪だよさんゲームオーバーです
やっぱに行った方がいいんですよこの
ゲームいやそうですねその説はちょっと
この2回から見てその可能性はあるねうん
じゃコンティニューしますお願いし
ますおいここからじゃなくていい
だろさあここですはいここはやっぱり
明るい道の方がいいとはいなのでここは
もう何も考えずAの明るい道に行きますお
願いします明るい道を選びましたおロード
入
ああよかったよあムービー来た
はい今日も疲れたな2すぎ
だろ虹だおめっちゃ綺麗じゃんあ虹ああ
すごいじゃえ回復するんじゃない
これ
はさっき
[音楽]
のなんか恥ずかしくさっきの女の人が
はい2人の出会いは運命だった彼女との
出会にカビネポイントが上がった
イエーイやっぱいい人生だと出会うんだ
そうねはいあ帰宅しました20
時結構かかった
な今日は寝坊しちゃったり素敵な出があっ
たり色々あった
なこんな日の夜はどう過ごすはいはいはい
これはどうしますささんもうさっき寝坊し
てるんですよはいはいはいさすがに早めに
就寝だと思うんですよねいいんじゃない
ですかねそれではいやっぱ人生無難に生き
た方がうまく成功していけるっていうのを
このゲームが教えてくれる気がしますなの
でAの早めに就寝にしますはいAポチあ
よしゆっくりめハピネスポイントがマタ
まで回復おめでございます回復しまし
たクリアですデバクリアあデきましたね
いいよサクサク進んでるよオッケー
オッケー今日も1日頑張る
ぞまずは昨日のメールの返信の確認とうん
どれどれ変身はあどうしたどうし
た大きなミスをしてしまっ
たやばいやばいやばいこれってあ減っ
ちゃいましたねちょっと
ちち超怖い部長に怒られちゃうどうしよう
でもまだハピネスポイントあるんでそうね
かなり
あるさあここで選択肢むしろ部長より勢い
よく自分にぶち切れてみるB他人のせいに
するうわ両方悪やんでもま部長より勢い
よく自分にぶち切れてみるわもう確かに
意味わかんないんでワンチャン首の可能性
ありますからはいせめてもしかしたら本当
に人のせいかもしんないんでうんうんうん
Bの他人のせいにするこれでなんとか自分
だけでも生き残ろうとしようと思います
そうですねそれもまた人生かもしれません
からねはいBポチさあ他人のせいに
[音楽]
する何でしょうか部長ああ怒られてますね
なんてことしてくれたんだ自分が何をした
か分かってるのか少しだけ待ってて
くださいああ他の人連れてきちゃった実は
このミスの原因は全部こいつなんです全て
の始まりはこいつからなん
です確かに他者に送る資料をテプしてまし
たがこいつの肘がぶつかってあそれはダメ
です
ね
ああゲームオーバーだやっぱりあれか他人
のせにしてはいけないのかもしれませんね
そうですねてなるとやっぱ上だったか上
の部長より切れると部長より切れてお前の
せいだろって部長のせいにする方が良かっ
たかもしんないじゃあコンティニューし
ますわはいお願いしますはいさあ来ました
はいこれはもうAなんではいえのむしろ
部長より勢をよく自分にぶち切れてみる
おしますお願いしますどうなるかが気に
なるよね
うんやっぱね怒られますよねはい
はいはい
[音楽]
はいやばい自分に切れてる受け入れた上で
ねどうやったらこんな店できるんだもう
引いちゃってるよ
部長
おおあ逆になんか慰めてくれてますね
急に体育会系おすごい乗り切ったかこれ
すごい
ぞでしょうねどんな人生あ乗り切りました
楽たけてるいけ
てるお
だなんか後ろのキャラバグってない大丈夫
かあ本当
だ手上げたままになってるよは大事な
プレゼンがあるとプレゼンを功させるたに
入れるには
ああ美味しいラ屋さんに行くかプレゼン1
時間前から準備ともうプレゼンて1時間前
に準備したところでも無駄なのでまもう
手遅れまであるよね準備してなかったら
はいもうここまで準備した部分でプレゼン
は大丈夫ですうんうんうんでちょっと
ハピネスポイント下がってるんですよそう
ね若干なのでちょっと回復読みの美味しい
ラーメン屋さんに行ってそういう準備をし
てプレゼンに望もうと思います
高めてねということでAのおいしい
ラーメン屋さんへを押しますいいんじゃ
ないですか
ポ休憩中は休憩した方がいいすかロード
入ったよ
えあムービー来ました見たあラーメンや
このラーメン屋来たかったんだよなお邪魔
し
ます誰もいない誰もいないぞ店員さんもい
ねえ
ぞ人気ラーメ屋なのに誰もねえ
な街の人もい
ねえなんだ何が起きてるんだ
え
えああたさん隕石落ってきてしまいました
いやこれラーメン行かなくても隕石落ちる
からラーメン行ったから隕石落ちたわけ
じゃないでしょこれ絶対さん行ったのは
間違いだったってことは分かりましたね
そうですねじゃもう選択肢Bを選ぶしか
ないんでそうねちょっとそっちやってみ
ましょうはいBしかないのでBプレゼン1
時間前から準備をしますお願いしますま
さっき見せもしてるからねその反省のイも
込めて早めに行く作戦だ
ねああいいすねいいす
ねあ準備してる時前
から資料を置いてます
ね準備してるね準備してますねこ細かく
丁寧
に電話
だ
おとととと
ああこれえ間違ってた
かああまずいよまずい
よ
あ
まずいこれはまずいんじゃないですかこれ
はかなりまずいよ
ああ張り切りすぎたのが恨みに出ちゃった
ねそうですねこれゲームオーバーじゃない
の
[音楽]
誰もプレゼン聞いてくれてないねえゲーム
オーバーや
ん
あや
やばあメンタル強いこれ大丈夫ですギリ
保って
ますああなんとかなんとか逃げきりました
ね耐え
た仕事でミスして怒られて室間違えて走っ
て疲れたなもう変ちゃったようん疲れた
からお腹空いたな
とはいはい夜ご飯ですねはい頑張って本格
料理を手作りうんスーパーのお惣菜
パーティーうんさたさんどうしましょうま
疲れてるんで本格料理を手作りするのは
体力的にとは思ううんうんうんてか僕も
はめさんもこういう時はスーパーのお惣
パーティーをしちゃうタイプあそうねなの
でBののスーパーのお惣パーティーで
ハピネスポイントをね回復したいなと思い
ます俺もねそうする気がするうんスーパー
のお惣菜パーティーうんおロード入りまし
たよよしよしよしムービー見れるってこと
ムービー見れます
[音楽]
ねムービーなのにこ感じかうわ美味しそう
どうめっちゃうまそうやお惣菜パーティー
でもうこれやばいっすよいいね
スーパーお惣パーティーとトセのコンボ
ですこれ
ああこれね
これ
[音楽]
ああうまそう
だこれもハピネスポイント回復しちゃうん
じゃないですか100%回復するでしょう
あと取るの
うま音
えぐCMでしか聞いたことないそうねうわ
これ
は完璧だ完璧だねこれはいただきますもう
お惣菜で完璧な夫人作っちゃってうんはい
自分の好きなもの買いまくってえもう
パーティーしちゃってるっていう状況です
ねこの時間が一番ねもう体力とか色々回復
するんですよね間違いないですもうああ
[音楽]
うああああ
素晴らしいマックスまで回復したおない
パーティーでハピネスポイントがアップ
明日も頑張るぞ
とこういう自分の好きな食べ物好きな
飲み物でパーティーしてもう好き勝って
食べるっていうこれで回復ハピネス
ポイントこれね1つの人生の攻略法だと
思いますいやそうですよ間違いない僕も
やりますもんこれマジで幸せだよねうん
これはデ2たさんクリアですよしたさん
Day3ですDay3まで来た結構進んだ
ね
うん自宅ですね10時大丈夫なの
か会社だとアウトだぞうんおはようあ連絡
が来てますねえあさんデートですこれあの
子ああまたやったわこいつ何やってんだ
さっちゃんとデートの約束してんだった
場所も何も決めてないのにどう
しようこれやってますわ
これやってるわなチャットAIに相談
めちゃくちゃ今時チャットAIに相談か
バックレるか
ですバックレるはあかんて1回やってみ
ますま見たいしそうねゲームだからそう
ですねどうなるか気になりますよねうんB
のバックレル行きますお願いします絶対
バックレダメだけどねこの選択肢あるのが
おもろいああまた寝ました
ね冷静に
なろうああまずい
[音楽]
まずいとりあえず出る
かまままこれはダメですよさすがに分かっ
てた分かってた分かってましたねこれに
より確実に正解が今導き出せましたから
はいコンティニューしますお願いしますま
AのチャットAIに相談しかないでしょう
今何でも答えてくれるしねはい分で考えろ
話ですけどはいまずはチャットAIに相談
しましょうそうねここではいえチャット
AIに相談し
ますチャットを使ってさっちゃんが喜び
そうなデートバを考えるぞはい
うん今人気のカフェとかねうん早速さちゃ
に提案してみよっ
と
おああうまくいきましたねいいじゃんさあ
デート来ました来まし
た
おおちょっとのおかげでデートの結果
ばっちりよかったね間に合ってよかった
よかっ
たではめく今日の私いつもと何か違うと
思わないああこの女の子から聞かれるやつ
ね
はいAに聞くなよオオさあこれ難しいです
ねBのイケボです褒めるはあの分かって
ないでしょってバレそうじゃないですか
確かに確かにもう抽象的だもんねはい勝負
Aありだなピンポイントでね
はいネイルの色を指摘紫からピンクに変え
たでしょで行きますこういうのね女の子
気づかれたら嬉しいってよく聞きますから
うんいいんじゃない
の
あ入りましたこれよよよしでしょ
わかるいやもちろん分かる
よネイル変えたでしょ
あた紫からピンク色にしたでしょえ何言っ
てんのえグレージからシアーピンクなんだ
けどシピンク間違えてシアピンクああ
やばい帰ったえ
止めろ気持ち分かる
けどああ絶妙な色の表現がポイントとなっ
てしまいましたねまでも仕方ないそうね
ここはちょっと難しいところでありました
ね結構難易度高い問題だったと思います
これうんとなるとってことだよねうんあ逆
にこれBでいいんだねBでいいんです
ねチャラいですけどねうん確かにはい
じゃあBイケボで褒める会う度に可愛く
なってるから毎回違うよでいきますはいお
願いし
ますあ入ったうんうん
うん
わかる当然さお君は会うたびに可愛くなる
から毎回違うよね何それ
ずるいうまい
ね恥ずかしくなっちゃうえうまいとかない
けど別
にああボディタッチありましたねこれは
嬉しいね
えあれ言う人間がこれでもじもじする
頑張ったんじゃないですか彼なりにでも
無事なんかいい雰囲気にはなってますけど
うんこれは大丈夫そうなんじゃないかあ
進みました
ねおよかった
[音楽]
じゃんどうしたん
だ見れないぞこれは見れ
ない
[音楽]
10月の27日何の日なんだとああAが
覚えてるよ誕生日だよねうんB適当に
答えるこ物ですねうんまだ出会って本当に
間もないですよねそうだねはい割とそんな
1日2日とかな感じはありますけどそれで
聞いてくる時点で誕生日以外なくないいや
間違いないねうん確信を持ってAを押し
ますこれは大丈夫でしょうさすが
にじゃないと聞かないよね
うんもちろん覚えてるよ今日はさっちゃん
のお誕生日だよね来
た
えああやばいゆみちゃんの誕生日だった
やばい遊んでんなあこれはダメです
ね
ああ他の女の子と誕生日間違えるのは非常
にまずいですこれ
まずいゆみちゃん誰ゆみちゃん誰だしさっ
ちゃんも聞くなでこれでもう次進めるね
はいBの適当に答える押しますハッピネス
ポイント減ってほしくないねうんせっかく
ね満タンです
からもちろん覚えてるよああの人の誕生日
かな
大正解だよあと1か月29日で徳川家康の
誕生日なん
だ
あ所ですかね女ですねあすごい話出し
てる秀吉家康の話をずっとしてる
なああなんか乗り切りました
すごピンポイント
でこ徳川の誕生日じゃなかった怒られたて
ことですよい怒られてましたね奇跡的に
乗り越えたようなシチュエーションですね
あそしてロード入ってますね
うんさあデートもよよ終盤かな夕方
です最高のスカはどれくらいなえ全然やっ
てないからわかんないけどあのガータ
ガータ100は100は行く100はギリ
あギリ行くんだどのくらいこれもでも
マックススコアが300えそれ全部倒して
んじゃんもうねガーターの仕方を知りたい
絶対倒すのよなんかそうなのよすごいね
うんいやいい雰囲気だよ
うんおお
えこれもうどうしますえ成功して欲しい
けど
な
ちょっと告白する前に成功するかどうかを
探るじゃないけどままそうねその温度感を
ねもうちょ確かめたいとこあるはい
ちょっとさりげなく手ついじゃおうかなと
思います酸っぱいお願いしますたさんBの
さげなく手をつぐ僕もつぎたいですお願い
します来たよこれ来た手つげるとこ見れ
るってことあもうだって手繋げる道にある
じゃん誘ってでしょああ何急にりえないん
だけどあ
ごめんああちょっと早かったか
ああ
[音楽]
ああ泣き方やば失恋しましたゲムオーバー
ですとなるとよはい
もう告白するしかないってことかこれ告白
されたらOKなのに手をつぐがダメてこと
どうなんだろうねあまちょっと見てみない
とわかないですねじゃあAの告白するおし
ますお願いします
うん好きです付きやってください発的に
行ったなえあれごめん
なさいダメだった
ダメなんだ耐えろうわギリいい感じだった
のに振られてしまったいやギリギリ耐えた
ねそうですね1個だけ残ったけどあぶねえ
どっちにしろじゃあこのタイミングでは
うまくいかなかったのかもしれないねうん
やっぱもっとねお互い知っていかないと
ダメだったか早かったかうさあ20時帰宅
してますうんどうにか立ち直ってほしいあ
もう歩くの
遅い
うまくいってたと思ったのにああまずいね
これは終わっ
たうまくいかないもんだ
なまそういうこともあるよな人生だったら
うんなんて悲しい夜なん
だまあでもこの状態でねやること全部わら
せてっていうのもねちょっとね大変かも
しんないね僕はふて寝します俺もふて寝し
ますはい1回寝かせてあげようはい疲れ
てるし1回ふてね寝てね嫌なことも忘れ
られることあるかもしんないからうんおお
ロード入った
[音楽]
ななんかもう疲れたな大丈夫か大丈夫か
大丈夫仕事行ける次の日
[音楽]
お起きたの
か3時間も経っ結構寝た
なあやばい
いやなんだ
か寒いな
ああ最後のハピネスポイントがなくなって
しまいましたそっか1だったのか追い込ん
じゃったみたいな感じのかなとなればもう
りえてBじゃないですかやること全部
終わらせて1人のみとそうはいじゃあBの
やること全部終わらせて1人のみをします
行き
ましょう来たビジも明るいよよしやるかね
もうなんか切り替えられてる感じの音楽が
うんもうしっかり食べてます
[音楽]
ねこの音がまだ諦めてない
よ
お皿も洗ってるのか
ないやあえらいね
えらいちゃんと仕事もしつつあきました
よしトリスです今日は濃いで行くかあ今日
は濃いですよまこういう日はね普通の
トリスよりちょっとウイスキーの味を
しっかりと楽しめる濃のトリスもじっくり
味わいたい夜ですようん
いやこのやるべきことを終わらせた後の
解放された状態のトリスも最高の私服の
時間だと思ううんこれは100%ね
ハピネスポイント回復しますね回復します
ねややっぱこれだいやでしょう
ねいやいいよもテレビとか見て今日は
ゆっくりしなさいうんいい
ね
お
よさっちゃんからなんだびっくりして逃げ
ちゃったけどうん本当は嬉しかったん
だもし良かったら付き合って
みるや良かっ
たあ回復し
た良かった
あクリアですこのやるべきことを全て
終わらせて解き放たれた状態でのトリス
これもうめちゃくちゃ幸せだと思うので
うんこれ人生の攻略法の1つだと思います
こういう時間めっちゃ大事ですうんデイ4
です結構来たよ本当に結構来たなまた上げ
とるんかいずっと伸びしてるけど本だ帰っ
て
ない頑張れあろの引っかかってますけどま
ごいなこの
ゲームああまだめちゃくちゃだよ
ろんこれどういうことだ大丈夫かまたやっ
たんか資料の修正以来が来たけどやり方が
わからないどう
しよううわこれさどっち
もどっちですねでも僕的にチャットAIと
かに相談してたはじめ君が自分で考えて
行動っていううん択があるんだったら
ちょっと押してみたい気はするんですよね
ああそうだね成長を感じるよねちょっと
前向きなんだろうな今自分で考えて行動
しよういいんじゃないええ自分で考えて
行動そうだその精神
だよしよしよしよし
よし
あ尻遅れたんですねうんえ
え
ああ勝手に自分で進めないで相談しに来て
くれよ
ああそっかそっかああ落ち込んでるまだ
わかんないでも耐えれるかあ一気に0あ
一気にゼロめちゃくちゃ怒られたんだろう
なうわあ時には相談も大事ってことなん
ですかねこれそうですね分からない以上は
ねそうだねBすぐに上司に質問します
うん後ろのバグ治らないんか
[音楽]
なそうだねまずは聞こう
うんああバグのキャラがめっちゃ進んどる
見切れてるなあ
えああやばい結局どうすればいい
のうわもうどっち選んでも怒られるいる
いる人な時あるよね
うんあああ
ええこれどうする両方ゲームオーバーだよ
えどういうことどういうことどうすれば
いいんですかこれえどうすればいいのこれ
本当にとりあえず選択肢まで行くかはい
[音楽]
コンティニューえなんかあったああ第3の
選択肢来ましたABB失敗することによっ
てもう1つの考えが出てきてますねの解決
法を見つけ女子に相談するある程度考えて
から女子に相談するっていうなるほど両方
取りですねこれこれはCですこれは行き
ましたよ
はいそうね成長してるよいいんじゃない
のよしよし
よし
ちょっと地名的なバグがありますけども名
的だ
なはいはい
はいうん
うんえバグ目立つな
おおちるけどめちゃくちゃだよこの画面も
おお手押ししてるやんけいやでもうまく
いきましたねうん
あよしよしよしよしおおハピネスポイント
食めましたよしよしお昼時かな
うんまだまだあいつ壁にぶつかってるけど
おバグで挟まっちゃってんだ多分あれ
もうまお昼時ですねお前も手上げっぱなし
うんうんうんいいねハピネスポイント高い
からちょっとご機嫌だねうんやっぱ仕事の
休憩中なんでうんうんうん近くの美味しい
定食屋さんでいいかなとまそうね逆にこう
いう時こそねうんあんまりこう高飛車に
ならずねB近くの美味しい定食へ行きます
お願いし
ますえ
おさっちさっ
ちゃん可愛いなあこれロード入っちゃった
仕事中に
やばいなんだ
あおおはじめ
くさてないななんでここにいるのこれいる
よねこう付き合ってからおかしくなる
タイプの人いいじゃんいいじゃんえああ
意識しちゃってるなこれもし良かったらな
んだけど一緒にランチかどうかなどうかな
え付き合ってるんですよね付き合ってるね
行行こうかあ逆にその行うかお互い好きっ
ていうのが
恥ずかしいあえええええ何何食べよか
やばいやばい手投げてるよもう昨日の夜は
チャーハン食べたうんチャーハンかえじゃ
今日のお昼もチャーハンがいいかなあえ
うんビネスポイントマックスになっちゃ
どうしようかなああ良かったさお昼ご飯も
食べてオフィスに戻ってきたとスキップし
ちゃってんじゃんもうよしよしよ久々に
ミスなく進んだようんいい感じだねおや
おや
おやあ
ああさきバグってた社員が喧嘩してます
ね
わあ同僚2人が喧嘩している
とこれどうしますかねうんうんさっき部長
の票が上がったじゃんうんこれ逆に今仕事
自分の任せられたらうんめちゃくちゃ小心
のチャンスだと思うんですよ
ねとこれはビッグウェイブに乗るしかない
はいってことはBですねBで行きましょう
ハピネスポイントマックスだしねうんB
ドサに曲げれて自分の仕事を任せるにし
ます最低どう任せるんだこれ確かその手順
も気になるよね山盛仕事ファイルを装備し
た
はいはい喧嘩してます
ねあまあそうなっちゃいますよ
ねそうなるよ普通にそんなことするわけ
ないだろはお大丈夫か
ああ大丈夫か
これいろんなものを失ってる同僚の信頼
失って
ああこれはやってはいけないいってを踏ん
でしまったのかそうですだって満タンだっ
たのにもう会社でもうやばいやつみたいに
なっちゃったんだろうねささに自分の仕事
は自分でやんなきゃですねそれはそうじゃ
Aのするをします外ないよ
うん喧嘩の仕方おもろいななんか下向きな
んだ
[音楽]
よはいはいはいはいはいそうだね
うん
ああ収まりそうにないか
[音楽]
へ
解決するなよそれで
ああこれはこれは余計なこと言ってしまい
ました
ね
あああ3倍になっちゃったね
えああもう夜じゃん
うわ
ああ
えちょっとそこら辺でストップしてばなオ
オッケーまあ全然やだ
けどいやちょっといいことしたさが恨めに
たたというかうんこれは辛い
ね
まあちょっとお人しすぎるところがあり
ますねそうだねうんまけその場収まって
自分でこう抱え込んで無事残業して帰宅と
うん
えいなえいないい映像だったな今あ疲れ
てるよね
そりゃ俺
が何食べよっかなこういう日は何食べるか
なはいはいはいはいカップラーメンか魔像
カップラーメンはいあのね僕も
YouTuberですからはいこれの答え
はB魔界像カップラーメンなのは分かって
ますですが
はい普通のカップラーメンバージョンを見
てああそうねはいB行こうかなとどうなる
か知りたいよねそもそも1回A見てみます
はいもう分かってるよハズれなんでしょA
カップラーメン
[音楽]
こちいや寂しい
な追い込んじゃってるけどね
うんちょ元気出るんかなこれでき
ます泣いてね泣い
てるな美味しそうだけど
うんなん
だろうこの味噌ラーメしょっぱいなああ仕
になっちゃっ
てる涙の味がしてるんでしょう
ね追い込みすぎだ
よそれは悲しみが増しちゃうよ
うんまあまあこれはもうそういうことです
よねはいだったら改造して食べちゃいます
かはいお待たせしましたお願いしますはい
B魔像カップラーメン
ですさあどう改造するかうわチーズと
キムチだ絶対うまいこれです
よ
ああこれチーズ溶けるやつだよね腹減る
うわそして取りせたこんなもう最高や
ん
あまたいい映像うまそうだ
な魔界像カップラーメンとトリスの
組み合わせこれは
もうまた明日から頑張れるんじゃないの
うん嫌なことあった後にやっぱいいことも
ないとねうん人生やってらんないからはい
これで明日からも頑張れるよ
うんどチーズ溶けてる溶けてるね
めちゃめちゃうまそうなんだ
けどこの組み合わせがうわチーズ伸びてる
じゃん
はいこれは復活ですはい俺の今日の晩御飯
の組み合わせも決まりますたこれになっ
たらね
はいはいこれでトリスも飲んでいいねうん
ああこの時間があるだけで人生は楽しめる
よ明日も頑張るかよし
頑張れハブネスポイントが大幅アップ
よしあ人身は続く
おここまでですえここまでではい続きは
自分の人生で楽しんでくださいはいあの
やっぱ人生ってものはねもう永遠に続いて
いくものですからここから先どうなる
かっていうのはちょまだわかんないです
けどもこのゲームはここで終わりっぽい
ですなるほど気になるけどなちょっと気に
なるね嬉しいとか楽しい幸せと悲しいの
繰り返しがきっと人生だなっていうのはね
どうですたかこのゲームで伝わりました
か伝わりましたねなんか人生の
ね深
さ分かるかそんな
はいというわけで人生というゲームプレイ
してみたわけなんですけれどもたさんどう
でしたかそうですねも楽しかったのは
間違いないあ良かったよかったやっぱ人生
ってどうしてもちょっとずつダメージと
いうか削られるうんうんうん部分ってある
じゃないですか仕方ない瞬間あるよねそう
そういう時のその私服というかハピネス
ポイントが上がるそういった場面も
いっぱいあってでもマジ人生だなって思い
ましたね本当1部分というか山あり谷あり
ですよ本当に幸せなこともあれば辛いこと
もあるそれが人生というものでございます
家帰ってからの
ご飯大事すお素材パーティーとか魔改造
ラーメンそしてそれと一緒に飲むトリス
ああいう時間がですねきっと人生において
すごいこう幸せをもたらすというか人生を
楽しめる本当1つの攻略法なのかなと思っ
ておりますごめんあれ見てたら飲みたく
なったので飲みましょうはいたさんお疲れ
様ですお疲れ様ですいただき
[音楽]
ます最高や最高や魔像ラーメンもあるん
ですこれこれいいんですかマカラーメン
これ食べましょうこれとトリスがマジで
合うんですよ食べましょうか食べましょう
いただきますいただき
ますこれとが本当に合うんですよもう
ずっとやりたかった見て
からうわあいただきますいただき
[音楽]
ますうま冗談抜きうんマジ冗談抜き案件
関係ないやつはいこれとトリスが本当に
合うんです
よ
わあ合う人生って幸せだなで皆さんの人生
もきっと辛いことも嬉しいことも色々ある
と思いますが楽しんで人生遊んでいき
ましょうじゃあ
なDET